dora is five years old and an orphan her
previous owner kept her as a pet
illegally at the Frankfurt zoological
society's jungle school she is now
learning to survive in the wild first
lesson climbing a tree it's not as easy
as it seems the philosophy house are the
bars in their cages were thin but stable
and secure so here they venture out onto
tiny branches that are just as thin and
so they often come crashing down that's
massive / lucky coffee cup hmm how to
find food is one of the most important
lessons her trainers showed Dora how to
suck termites out of the nest and get
the goodness out of a stem of rattan
palm bukit tigapuluh is one of Sumatra's
largest remaining rainforests protecting
this unique environment is essential for
the orangutang survival
hundreds natsuko nothing maintaining
these protected areas is the key this
will decide whether the species will
still be around in the next millennium
leap toward opiod oscam nearby the
forest is being cleared to make way for
palm oil plantations some two-thirds of
Sumatra's rainforest has already
vanished Dora's days in the jungle
school are finally over deep in the
forest they find the perfect place to
set her free there's water close by and
they leave some food dora is well
prepared for freedom
sumvision viven yank it's like when your
kids finish high school and move out
it's hard for the parents but it's
what's supposed to happen and it's a
success picking up for it the
conservationists will keep an eye on
Dora until they're sure she'll be able
to thrive and breed in the wild